what is happening right now is we're
seeing an
inversion of reality right we're seeing
we we all kind of had a basic
understanding of the world
and we all you know we squibbled over
whatever but we that now
has been completely turned up upside its
head and i i think actually the
the great example of this is the in it's
why everyone's talking about this gender
issue
it is the insistence that we must
go along with this ideology that says a
man is a woman and a woman is a man
it's it's only one minor issue but it's
a symbol of the broader problem and
we are told by the doctor fouches of the
world
these people who have no accountability
to the people whatsoever
that if we question what they want us to
do
that changes every single day in
political calculations that we are
anti-science
and anti-democracy they'll say if we the
people
question what these totally
unaccountable elites do in contravention
of the laws that we are threatening
our democracy and i i often think of
angelo codevilla who's the scholar at
the claremont institute
who pointed out that whenever they refer
to our democracy what they really mean
is
their oligarchy it's totally totally the
opposite so we're
we are just in the upside down
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host
of the aptly titled michael knowles show
on the daily wire and the author
of the brand new book speechless
controlling words
controlling minds michael knowles
welcome back to the reuben report
dave thank you for having me it's good
to be with you i felt my intro there was
very
professional broadcastery because you're
a professional broadcaster and i felt
and you enunciate
very well and you with the posture and
the whole thing how'd i do there
i was very impressed and look the book
the whole book is about words
your addiction your articulation
beautiful beautiful all right let's get
the stuff we gotta get out of the way
right up top
uh you screwed me everybody knows you
screwed me it's been talked about many
times i'm brought on other shows they
asked me about it
uh yeah we were having drinks uh last
spring you were at my house with your
lovely wife
and we were drinking whiskey and eating
steak and we decided in a drunken stupor
that we were both going to stay and
fight in los angeles and dethrone
gavin newsom and keep the union together
and it was very exciting and then i
couldn't wait morning
it was announced that you were moving to
nashville well yes
that uh was now in in my defense dave
i was very excited i was filled with
pure vitriol against gavin nussolini
i we had imbibed quite a bit we were in
your beautiful
home oh we were ready to go then i walk
in
and you know what happens here at the
daily wire they i walk into the room you
know what
they say jump and you know what i say
dave how high
that's what i how high and i jumped so
far that i'm in tennessee
you are in tennessee i saw you you're
settling in how's it going for the daily
wire in tennessee are you guys happier
now that you've left los angeles
left me left dennis prager and the one
other decent person in this craptastic
town
it's got there's got to be one i'm sure
there's well uh gary cities
gary yes gary sinise would be there
corolla
yeah no see there are some there's some
people left but it's true a ton of
people are fleeing and they're flying to
three places
tennessee texas and florida florida now
is like the
truly the last bastard if it's just
going to break off and float into the
atlantic ocean
it's great my little newborn son who was
he was born here
is going to have a little southern drawl
the first knolls probably ever to have
one
it's good i i have guns i have money
i breathe the sweet air of freedom
people are nice and normal here
it's it's it turns out that the that
little part of america the little part
between new york and l.a you know you
might have heard of it
it's actually a pretty nice place you
mean we shouldn't just think of it as
flyover country there's actually some
decent people there and decent customs
and
no you can land a plane actually it's
not you can actually land it here and
there's like stuff to do and people and
it's nice yeah they're just absolutely
incredible do you think
i mean now that you know some time has
gone by almost a year actually since we
had that conversation at my house
do you think i'm bananas i mean what do
you think of the remaining people who
are trying to
keep you know these states not from
going into complete progressive literacy
although maybe
it's done already i don't know i i think
you are bananas i know
the kind of the formal excuse for this
sit-down was that we were going to talk
about the book or whatever
this dave this is an intervention
your friends love you very much we want
to see you happy we don't want to see
you
hurting yourself and every minute that
stay in that hellscape uh in california
you it that is you're inflicting harm on
yourself
and on society you got to get out you
got to come to the sweet land of freedom
plus you had fried baloney there which
was really something
not just the the air and the money and
whatever else you said it was also the
probability all right before we get to
the book let's just
do a little recap of what's going on in
the world because i haven't we haven't
sat down together in a while it's been
well i did your show when i was in
nashville a few weeks ago we got we got
drunk in the middle of the day that was
fun
uh but the last time we sat down was uh
when i came back on the grid and you
you welcomed me back so a lot has
happened obviously the world is just
completely bananas
what what's your grade if you had to
grade the state of the world right now
what are you feeling uh well i think it
resists
letters i think we've if we're doing a
through f
we no no we and we go down to z no and
you try the greek alphabet
they're renaming all the covid variants
it's no longer the
indian variant or whatever that's
politically incorrect so now it's
they're using
greek letters like omega and pi and
they're saying that's much simpler
it it even goes beyond the greek uh
alphabet
what is happening right now is we're
seeing an inversion
of reality right we're seeing we we all
kind of had a basic
understanding of the world and we all
you know we squibbled over whatever but
we
that now has been completely turned up
upside its head
and i i think actually the the great
example of this
is the in it's why everyone's talking
about this gender issue
it is the insistence that we must
go along with this ideology that says a
man is a woman and a woman is a man
it's it's only one minor issue but it's
a symbol of the broader problem and
we are told by the doctor fouches of the
world
these people who have no accountability
to the people whatsoever
that if we question what they want us to
do
that changes every single day in
political calculations that we are
anti-science
and anti-democracy they'll say if we the
people
question what these totally
unaccountable elites do in contravention
of the laws
that we are threatening our democracy
and i often think of
angelo codevilla who's the scholar at
the claremont institute who pointed
out that whenever they refer to our
democracy what they really mean is
their oligarchy it's totally totally the
opposite so we're
we are just in the upside down right i
know i can drop a star wars reference
with you but it was only a few weeks ago
that fauci said if you're against him
you're against science which is very
palpatine i am the senate
you know it is i always i always assumed
i thought i thought palpatine would be
like joe lieberman or something you know
they kind of bear that physical
resemblance
no it's tony fauci that's that's the man
the lockdowns you you were pretty much
against all of it from the beginning
right like you were i'll give cred i'll
give credit where it was due
you were pretty much against all of this
from beat one was there did you have a
little window
what were you doing in that two week to
flatten the curve thing no i i had no
window i mean i i've been licking
doorknobs
since this virus was announced uh i was
willing
to entertain the idea that
the government has sort of emergency
powers during a pandemic so when they
said
two weeks to slow the spread i i said
this is a bad idea i don't like it i'm
against the masks i'm against all of it
but it is within our political tradition
for certain governments and ideally more
local governments
to take these kinds of actions but the
problem with it
and i knew it from the top and i think
you know it and a lot of us knew it
is it was never what they said it was
they said that it was about two weeks to
flatten the curve we knew the minute you
give them this kind of power it's not
going to be two weeks it's not it's not
gonna be 15 days it's not gonna be 15
months it's still going on right now
they said that the reason we need to
wear the masks well sorry
after they told us not to wear the masks
when they told us we had to wear the
masks
they told us the reason for that is it
will help us get back to normal
but but i knew as i think anyone with
common sense do
the masks not only won't help us get
back to normal it will they will ensure
that we never get back to normal
because when you see someone wearing a
mask that symbol does not tell you
oh good everything's normal again that
that thing we've never
been in a culture where everyone is
covering their face and muscling
themselves
that tells us we are living in
extraordinary and extraordinarily
dangerous times
and ever all the normal rules of
engagement have to be suspended
and that has continued there are still
people wearing those muscles today
isn't it interesting how they at first
were saying oh we'll get
back to normal meaning two weeks to fly
to curve then we'll get back to normal
but then it did shift
a certain amount of months in it shifted
to no there's a new normal
those are very very different things
they they told us there's a new normal
and i asked scientists even scientists
who are
broadly more conservative you know who
are more in the center
and i said so what's up with these masks
is this ever going away
and i kid you not some of them told me
well michael look
yes it'll go away as a permanent measure
but you know maybe every flu season the
masks come back i mean mike
it's really crazy before before we were
so crazy
we shook hands with people oh that's we
can't return to that
we didn't wear masks on airplane i mean
you know so some of that is just that's
the way we're gonna live now and i
thought
you you people have lost your minds if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell